august 21
so we came for pre
exhibition at mac copenhagen
it is very important for
culture living time explained for danish
mandela she came from the beginning it is
one in india 2500 years ago before and the
buddhas and  the birth then he 7th
century the buddhism le was to rise
motivated so 7th century is to rush you
en masse an arm and she came at
that time and man 2 took her from india
to tibet
so this world there  it is important
represents and on the planet the earth the
peace construction of the manic and and all
the living
today we are going to make mandela
it is the manna of the field sic
sertic buddha of compassion the fight
sion it represents of all  the
living peace swore and inside so
today particularly
we need peace in the world
specially the monks who had to done
and it was exhibition is
building mandela it is important
different different color  of
different movements of construction
would be very important every detail the
details red black white blue sarraut
need symbols of levon symbol of
the era symbol of the earth symbol of the a
symbol of the foot
how
when it finishes there will be to lecture
the months it  going to dance in its crisis and
the gaza strip are obviously afraid we
find there from the east mandela who will
destroy speaks diagana three parts a
fair and a scholarship you have
to put your album on
then they tell me all the sands in
the  river